says exercises
stretching exercise
so when you're taking a kimmy and says
up you're going to be put into a lot of
strange positions if you're not used to
sitting and says these are going to be
hard for you so one of the good things
to practice is to stretch the top of
your quads here and your hip flexors as
you come back so one way to do that is
bring your hands behind yourself and
slowly walk yourself back now ideally
you'd like to be able to do this until
you can come all the way flat when
you're in this position you don't want
to be feeling anything in your lower
back if you feel anything in your lower
back you should push your hips down so
you don't feel anything in your lower
back um and if you if you can't do that
and keep the pain from happening in your
lower back don't go that low yet come
back about this far right or this far
however far it is you need to go back to
be comfortable in that position slowly
as you're training you want to get
yourself so you have more and more
flexibility so coming back here like
this isn't a problem if you can do this
with no pain in your body then if you
get knocked back this way when you're
taking your kimi it won't really be a
big deal from here it's not so bad to be
able to shift your feet out like this
also
stretching exercises from suwatiwaza
you